Threading the carriage for plating
can be a bit tricky on this machine.
Just remember that the point is to have
two yarns in the number one yarn feeder
positioned so they remain
separate as you're knitting.
Looking very closely at the yarn feeder,
there are two openings
that will be used for the plating.
The goal is to have one yarn
in the regular opening and the contrasting
yarn in that back slot.
The easiest way I found to thread
that back opening is to use a double-
eye needle or a darning needle.
Thread the needle with your yarn
and slip it down through that back slot.
The manual suggests
pushing a latch tool up from underneath
the carriage and using the hook to catch
the yarn, and then pull the yarn
down to thread it in the feeder.
Using a work hook from a ribber works too.
Whichever method you use, make sure that
the two yarns are in separate feeders.
They move smoothly
and they're not hung up anywhere.
Now, with the yarns positioned this way,
I can knit my plating.
One yarn will be positioned
in front of the other.